how did a Gyptian hieroglyphs give birth
to the alphabet even in these ancient
times Egyptian monuments have been
sitting and weathering for thousands of
years on their great murals and pillars
you find rows of little pictures sorry
not pictures hieroglyphs sacred symbols
but despite appearances this isn't some
mysterious fairy onic picture writing
its consonants one consonant signs two
consonant signs three consonant signs a
wall of consonants plus a sprinkle of
logographs for determinative it's not
that Egyptian was a harsh vowel less
desert of a tongue it simply did not
write at the bowels imagine if you wrote
this way would that work and then
imagine if you could add in logographs
to make sure you really got your point
across
imagine you wrote like that and you're
thinking with hieroglyphs too difficult
fine off to the caves with you where you
toil away with ancient miners on the
Sinai Peninsula
you and your fellow miners would find it
handy to leave messages for one another
but there's no time for deep studies of
rows of fancy hieroglyphs in here you
need to keep it simple if you want
another major moments in the history of
writing your characters look like
scratchy rushed version of those
glamorous Egyptian symbols but their
meeting doesn't matter anymore nothing
but consonants and the same symbol for
the same consonant every time take this
character in Egyptian it means house
these Semitic miners are calling a house
a bet acropole or top sounds suggest
that you can just take the first letter
of a word like the egyptians had already
been doing with much of their consonant
writing you end up with a letter for
your sound but do the same thing with
water which the semitic speakers are
calling mem and you now have an mm sound
with a couple dozen elegant
simplifications you create a simple
reliable list of consonants an alphabet
and you've given generations of future
children the joys of reciting their ABCs
actually at this point in history there
a B G DS sometimes called an abjad or
abroad because who needs that
wishy-washy C when you can just use an S
or a K after a long hard day of mining
and etching you turn to find that
someone's been watching you this whole
time
she's a trader a Phoenician merchant who
knows a good thing when she sees it
she's already made major cash in the
paper business where they turned tough t
stocky swampy Egyptian papyrus
into flat ink couple sheets of paper she
rushes back home to Phoenicia and smirks
think of the advantage she has keeping
track of whatever anyone else tells her
just by remembering about as many
characters as she has fingers and toes
old kings can keep their obtuse
hieroglyphs and their stone monuments
the future of the Mediterranean will
belong to alphabets and paper writing is
going portable she uses this newfound
alphabetic leverage to turn a huge
profit across the entire eastern
Mediterranean leaving people inspired to
adopt and adapt her alphabet wherever
she goes all this and she doesn't even
write you a thank-you card
how hard could it be writing is easier
than ever
it feels universal like writings here to
stay for everyone but there's a peculiar
quirk that's easier to spot in hindsight
you and your mining crew we're
communicating in a semitic language
Phoenicians a Semitic language all of
these friendly shades of the Phoenician
alphabet were being used for languages
that sounded similar and worked much the
same way even Egyptian though no Semitic
language itself is at least a distant
relative of the Semitic languages with a
similar personality this consonant
alphabet is being tested in easy waters
but history is shaking things up your
merchant friend comes back for your help
she needs you to deliver your alphabet
to a very different people living along
her trade route
what will happen when the alphabet gets
leaked outside of the family
you